i am joined with my partner in crime
today paul scheer
yes all right let's share some of the
stories that we're thankful for
and we're going to be making actually
hand turkeys while we do this right paul
okay i love it i got my i got my uh
construction paper
i got my scissors i stole my kid's
markers right off his desk
perfect and what i'm going to say is my
favorite thing to do every thanksgiving
which is
i can't do that oh wow
okay our first story a few weeks back
ktvt in dallas reported that a 14 year
old
anika shabrolu won a
25 000 prize for developing
a possible treatment for covid19
anika used biomedical software to design
a molecule that could stop the function
of the proteins in coronavirus
at 14 anika oh my gosh
wow when i was 14 i was trying to beat
sonic the hedgehog
this is uh this is next level i mean
this is what we need
ah that gives me like hope for humanity
and the future and wow she's gonna save
us all
paul what's your story uh drew did you
know that there is a town
that has a dog as its mayor uh
that's right um yes this town has a
french bulldog as a mayor
um and i gotta read you some of the
stats here over 44
000 people voted for this mayor you know
you may think he ran
on like a platform of like uh give me
liberty or give me milk bones but he
actually ran on
a platform of mental health and breast
cancer awareness
uh so this dog is doing a lot of good
work
he knocked out uh breneth paltrow which
was a
uh dog that was in before him and what's
actually really amazing about this
is uh it costs money to vote in this
election and the reason why it costs
money is it's for charity
so they are raising charity uh so that's
really
amazing they're raising charity for
mental health awareness i
love this story now this is politics we
can get behind okay this next story
actually comes from toronto
cbc reports that a carpenter
named khalil siebright is
building insulated shelters for homeless
people in the community and his designs
work off body heat
which keeps it around 60 degrees in the
winter
and the shelters aren't authorized by
the city but khalil says that they're a
temporary solution
for survival this is wonderful
this is the kind of stuff i need to hear
absolutely i mean
it just it makes me incredibly emotional
by the way
i'm i am a little worried about my hand
turkey
i i don't know if i'm doing this well
i'm also trying to make a bow tie and
what it really looks
like is like pinwheels it doesn't look
like a bow tie
at all drew i'm impressed with your
turkey
you have a lot more props than i have
you're not gonna this my turkey is sad
okay paul i'm so sorry did you have
another story
you know this has been like you said a
really uh
tough year and i found this article um
on new york magazine's
website if they have this thing called
the strategist and it was all about how
to take
better photos and they have these
amazing classes that you could take
from your house it will teach you how to
do photoshop it will teach you how to go
out in the street and take pictures and
for me
you know since we haven't been able to
get out of the house that much or you
know we're doing it in a limited time
i'm just now bringing my camera around
and i'm just taking pictures of my kids
and my wife
and i feel like i would never have made
time for that
amount of learning so i'm thankful for
that and i think a lot of people are out
there doing
all of that well i don't know what this
is paul uh
but i love it uh yours i'm i look at it
and i'm like oh it's a turkey this i
look at and i'm like
what the heck is that but you know we
just failed kindergarten drew did we
just fail out
that's my second time doing that so
that's fine um and you know what i'm i'm
still here
so paul scheer everyone your documentary
by the way marvel
616. yeah i have a documentary it's
gonna be on disney plus
it's a part of this a series of eight
short films they're about an hour each
and uh
it covers an area of marvel and i
basically came to the realization that
to make it in hollywood i have to attach
myself to a marvel character
so i go on a deep dive of finding the
weirdest characters in the marvel
universe
they'll make you cry they'll make you
laugh and they'll make you inspired
yeah i know it looks incredible i'm so
excited for it and i'm so excited to
hang out with you
here doing the news with you is the best
and again
your backdrop is sublime so are you and
your whole family and thank you so much
we'll see you soon
you